chiche en
place une double à la manif donc vanille
way
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
du
double donc d'accord aa c'est de la
bonne centre la
glace
[Musique]
j'en
annan
on collait bien la haye est pas bien
olala
ça s'arrête
et des mois et des mois appuyez sur le
bouton là le bouton la silla monte monte
monte la vache
calèche déchets droit voila voila
macro laver les mains et servir sinon je
ne prends pas de là bas pour que tu
aimes faire chier parce que c'est un
acquis 1 voilà quoi qu'il arrive voilà
aux [ __ ] animé par tous or
cet arrêt
désert
comme la plage était enfin le barp
rdc
sage et or met encore un peu quand même
bon allez quoi nous nous non encore un
peu en cinq ans sans travail voilà ça
fait 10 euros bien disent
oh vous vouliez ou non vous m'avez d'une
grosse non plus et d'une petite bande du
zodiaque ultime alors ça c'est 10 euros
celle là ah bah non
olalala ce que je tenais
[Musique]